ante un parlamento sitiado por la
policía así como manifestaciones a favor
y en contra el presidente pedro castillo
ha negado estar inmerso en actos de
corrupción y en ese sentido el
mandatario le ha pedido a la fiscalía
que todo aquel funcionario aliado que
encuentre actos ilícitos le caiga todo
el peso de la ley y responda por sus
acciones el mandatario también ha
señalado que él no ha caído en
contradicciones ante las investigaciones
de la fiscalía tal como habían señalado
por los legisladores y opositores al
respecto diversos congresistas han
señalado que pero casi yo lo único que
está haciendo es tratar de impresionar
al congreso para que éste no reúna los
87 votos que se requieren para retirarlo
del cargo francisco y explicarle a
nuestra audiencia por qué se activó esta
vez está vacancia contra pedro castillo
cuál es el principal argumento en su
contra
bueno esta segunda vacancia contra pedro
garcía se inicia a raíz de las
declaraciones que hace una lo vista una
empresaria peruana identificada como
kari lópez ella acudió a la fiscalía a
solicitar un trato de colaboración
eficaz que es una relación premiada y
para ello dijo que tiene información y
ha sido testigo de algunos tratos que se
han hecho en el gobierno de pedro
castillo el mandatario ha sido acusado
por karim y lópez de dirigir una
organización criminal dentro del palacio
de gobierno que él cuya finalidad es
conseguir dinero para cancelar las
deudas contraídas durante su campaña
electoral esto ha suscitado que el
parlamento inicie investigaciones y hay
20 puntos que están señalando acusan al
presidente de estar en malversación
irregularidades como el ascenso a
policías convocatorias a personajes que
son cuestionados y aún así por tener un
prontuariado policial ha sido nominado
como ministro de estado hay diversas
acusaciones de haber recitado en las
reuniones clandestinas a proveedores del
estado y sin embargo castillo dice que
todo esto se trata de corrupción
brevemente porque afirma esto
en realidad lo que pedro castillo así
como sus simpatizantes
señalan que esto es una venganza de la
derecha que no lo acepta a él como el
presidente y él señala que precisamente
estos grupos de derecha están inmersos
en corrupción en las gestiones
anteriores con la empresa odebrecht así
como otras empresas que han se enseña la
comprado
autoridades en este país y ha afectado
esto esta situación que promueve una
crisis que está latente y bueno vamos a
ver qué sucede este 28 de marzo